Hey, Thoughty2 here.
Japan is probably the most health-conscious
country in the world.
They have the highest life expectancy, the
most centenarians per capita and they eat
sooo much fish.
As a country, Japan has gone to extraordinary
lengths to maintain its reputation as the
World’s healthiest place.
For instance, the vast majority of Japanese
companies make their employees do mandatory
exercise for half-an-hour every morning before
they sit down to work.
Studies show this not only helps physical
fitness, but also keeps employees mentally
sound and improves productivity.
But Japan doesn’t have a health craze like
Los Angeles, you won’t find any seaweed
and dust diet-fads here.
A healthy-lifestyle is just a deep-rooted
part of the Japanese Culture.
But with the influx of Western fast food Japan’s
healthy outlook is showing signs of crumbling,
under a mountain of melty-plastic-cheese.
And in a country where only 3% of the population
are overweight, tiny when compared to Australia
at 60%, those few people who are obese, tend
to stick out like a sore thumb.
It’s becoming a major problem, because so
few Japanese are overweight there’s a lot
of prejudice towards the not-so-small minority.
It’s common for overweight individuals to
be bullied in the workplace and even cast
out of their family, just for packing a few
extra pounds.
Normally governments combat obesity with hopeless
advertising campaigns and even taxing junk
food.
But Japan went the extra mile and simply made
it illegal to be fat.
In 2008 Japan’s lawmakers passed a law called
the “Metabo Law” which is short for metabolic
syndrome.
You may be watching this thinking Japan has
finally lost it, but the Metabo law isn’t
as extreme as it seems.
You won’t be locked up just for being overweight.
So what is the punishment for committing the
heinous crime of eating too many cheeseburgers?
Seppuku?
No, it’s a bit more complicated than that.
Under the Metabo law every Japanese citizen
between the age of 40 to 75 years-old, that’s
44 per cent of the population, has to have
a mandatory check of their waistline every
year.
The government states that the legal maximum
waist circumference for men is 35.4 inches,
whereas for women it’s only 31.5 inches.
So this law is basically a massive slap in
the face to guys who like curvy women.
To put these insanely restrictive numbers
into perspective, In Japan it’s considered
gross and illegal to have a waist over 35
inches as a male, whereas the average male
waist size in America is 40 inches.
If during their annual checkup, a citizen
is found to have a larger waistline than the
government imposed limit, they are required
by law to attend regular counselling sessions,
because you know, according to Japan if you’re
fat it must be because you’re mentally unstable.
And you have to regularly consult a dietitian
to discuss dietary options.
Whilst the penalty for individuals focuses
on rehabilitation, there are heavy fines for
companies that don’t follow the guidelines.
Under Metabo law companies are required to
monitor the waistlines and general health
of all their employees and encourage regular
exercise and a healthy lifestyle.
If a company is found the have employees with
illegal waistlines they must pay heavy fines
to the government until everyone in their
business has shed their excess baggage.
In fact, fines for companies can be as high
as $19 million dollars, just because someone
in the office is a greedy bugger.
To avoid these fines companies have resorted
to handing out so-called “Metabo Towels”
to all their employees, which is a towel with
a built-in tape measure, so employees can
keep a check on their waistline when they
step out the shower each morning.
Those crazy Japanese may seem, well, crazy.
But this controversial law has worked, obesity
rates have dropped significantly since its
inception in 2008.
Well done Japan, but seriously guys, you didn’t
even have an obesity problem in the first
place.
Thanks for watching.